pilier de notre patrimoine la
gastronomie à l'honneur à l'occasion de
la Semaine du Goût toute cette semaine
tvtour vous propose d'explorer les
recettes et produits de notre terroir
commençons par deux références le
sainemort de Touren et surtout l'ériette
avec cette question épineuse Aurélien je
vous vois sourire les meilleures
sont-elles celles de tour ou duum on a
travaillé dans les deux endroits réponse
loin d'être évidente comme vous allez le
voir dans ce test à l'aveugle réalisé
par la Turquier et Faustine
lunau
[Musique]
tout le monde connaît le sainteem de
Touren mais sauriez-vous le reconnaître
rien qu'au goût aujourd'hui nous allons
tester le palais des tourangeau sur leur
propre spécialité avec même un produit
mystère à la fin vous le verrez c'est
parti la première manche il va falloir
différencier les riettes du Man et les
riettes de tour
oh en tout cas il y en a une qui est
plus foncé que l'autre tu très gout ça
c'est le MAN que celle-là c'est tour et
celle-là c'est le M ile de tour et de du
man j'ai l'impression que je la connais
mieux mais je la connais très bien
celle-là pour moi la première cellelà
tour c'est lesquel les meilleur surtout
celle de tour celle du M du coup je me
dis qu'elle est de tour celle qu'elle
est meilleure ah bah vous êtes trompé
merde h non c'était le contraire c'était
celle de tour celle-là donc vous
préférez celle de tour ah bah ouais
c'est une bonne nouvelle oui bien tenter
mange fromage il y a du sainem et du sel
sur Cher déjà ça se ressemble un peu
mais après c'est la femme qui change fa
au moins qu'on en ait un de bon parce
que sinon c'est gênant vous reconnaissez
des saveurs peutêtre Mo j'achète des
très bons produits en tout cas ah c'est
excellent ah B moi j'ai préféré le
premier oui mais l'autre il était plus
fort ouais celuilà le deuxème selle sur
cher sainemt ou s sur Cher et sainteemt
pour le coup ah ouais ouais vous vous
avez raison c'est bien ça l'honneur et
sauf vous avez tous les deux torts je
sais pas si plus salé aussi celle-là je
me suis dit peut-être si un jeu de moi
avec sal sur Cher pas du tout en vrai
c'est pas facile mais je sais pas c'est
pas c'est une habitude je pense on a une
dernière manche c'est un produit mystère
du coup je vais vous demander de fermer
les yeux j'ai peur un
peu je sais pas c'est c'est un peu sucré
ça sent un petit biscuit avec un truc à
l'intérieur là du raisin ça non il y a
du raisin on dirait des petits gâteau
mais ouais un gâteau local non je sa pas
du tout ah aucune idée alors là je suis
pas spécialisé en biscuit c'est des
Palas sologo de la biscuiterie de
chambor
ok ben c'est cool je découvert un truc
c'est bon ouais ok Ctait bon bon a
priori il y a encore un peu de travail à
faire les tours en jou il va falloir
réviser vos classiques on compte sur
vous